I gotta say I was horrified watching
this video as a mom let me just tie it's
disturbing on so many levels every frame
raises disturbing questions and we're
getting to the bottom of it
[Music]
Jenelle Evans can be seen reaching for
what appears to be a handgun while her
frightened son Jason looks on the 26
year old reality star confronts the
driver who TMZ identified as Robert
Robinson jr. she says he cut her off
then slammed on his brakes causing her
to almost veer off the road while the
shocking incident took place in April
MTV didn't air the footage until last
night's episode going to black at the
moment Evans allegedly pulled out her
firearm and featured it Owen hurt you I
can go this knife gun and Whittle the
mom of three who has since denied
pulling out a gun proceeded to follow
Robinson home Robinson however tells TMZ
he did have a gun in his truck but
exercised restraint when he saw every
son in the car police responded to the
scene but this isn't the first time the
controversial Evans has had a run-in
with law she's been arrested 15 times
among the charges assault of which she
was found not guilty
ét reached out to Evans and MTV who did
not respond by our deadline a source
close to production tells us she's still
on the show and we will see her in
future episodes and today husband number
2
David Eason who's been kicked off the
show posted this pic with the caption
ain't we something
[Music]